et ces mecs là et venez me voir et me
dit il faut 50 grammes pour aller
braquer dix années passent encore
comment vous avez décidé de tout
balancer à il y en a certains c'est par
vengeance comme marwa chirac ou des roms
vous parlez de jacques chirac jacques
chirac ancien président doit de la
cocaïne dont il est issu
mais l'une à la louche incroyable avec
dassault moi j'étais web et j'ai fait un
seul coup et vous avez vous un procès
pour ce livre non j'ai aucun produit
depuis deux ans et demi que je suis là
j'ai eu aucun procès parce que j'ai dit
la sauce extrêmement grave pour les
familles mines d'aurillac qui nous
regardent dit la vérité vous
demandez-vous lui demander de venir
aider qui dort de 10h de true blood
vient aider tous et dès qu'ils sortent
de trois bébés et tout le monde s'est
pas mouillé la normale et il dit ce
qu'il a vu précisez bien julien delarue
mais on est passé à autre chose il ya eu
il ya eu la cocaïne abandonné pardonnez
moi ou c'est commencer une espèce de
cocaïne mondaine très précisément au
début des années 90 notamment à canal d
années passées à cordes mais il ya aussi
le problème des médicaments mais aussi
pour tenir à séoul
il ne sait pas qu'un problème de cocaïne
jamais et quand on dit il ya certains
dont on pas et dont on n'apprenait pas
d'un designer mais l eau mais un vrai
jacques chirac c'est vrai que c'est
hallucinant girard ouais bah ouais c'est
vrai mais si vous étiez son fournisseur
mais j'étais son fournisseur mange
jamais jamais deux lieutenants
1 c'était limal qu'un israélien qui
avait fait ça allait tout est son nom
cousin était chauffeur de chirac et donc
il venait me prendre 100 grammes par
semaine poursuit raid 100 grammes par
semaine
oui mais c'est la clé avec tout ça tout
les xixe et c'est fou oui non moi sommes
un peu plus huppé
alors voyez un truc aussi j'ai lu dans
votre livre vous avez notamment déclaré
avoir été le fournisseur de johnny
hallyday je suis fan absolu de johnny
c'est issam a délivré tout je dis que
parce que quand on juge d'instruction
m'a dit vous
et vous excuser auprès des gens que vous
avez empoisonné gili part dans macg pas
compris à me dire oui oui vous avez
compris je dis bah écoutez moi au
contraire on devrait me donner l'ordre
du mérite en france ah oui bah oui parce
que grâce à moi de jeunes et à l'idée
tenait dans ses portes dans ses concerts
il à ses deux amis qui a fait comme
jonny cocker n'emploie pas les jeunes
qui nous regardent et même jour là
pendant le sujet sur ophélie winter vous
me disais heureusement j'en suis sorti
ah oui qui moi oui mais oui heureusement
bien sûr je sais trente années c'est un
poison et un poison
je veux pas me faire l'apologie ses 75
ans et je suis parti je n'ai pas la
science
je n'ai jamais dormi nuit dans un
hôpital samba oui mais bon je prends
l'exemple jean luc delarue qu'ils
acquittent à 48 ans lui mais lis pas
pareil d'abord il buvait beaucoup
ben oui mal pour effacer les effets de
l'alcool chez la cocaïne drogue c'est
pas d'avaler révéla m on ne peut pas
dire gérard fauré que la drogue c'est
pas dangereux on peut pas dire que la
drogue c'est pas chic pas là oui c'est
pas sérieux comme un charme parce qu'on
a pris de la drogue
vous avez une chance insolente et vous
entendez vous êtes en bonne santé tant
mieux pour vous mais on peut pas dire
aujourd'hui à une heure de grande écoute
à la télévision lui en 16 c'est
formidable la drogue et grâce à moi